[Music]
don't slam the door
Damien I want to slam the den I saw
flower today shouldn't be long now
before spring or there's still a few
more weeks of winter left and that
flower will die cold and alone or that
either way winner can't last forever
Celine with any luck we'll be able to
get out of this cabin soon luck
doesn't keep the fire going luck won't
change the weather and luck definitely
won't put food on the table well I mean
if you think about it you probably do
need some luck and finding something to
eat in the middle of winter out in the
snow good luck
whatever try not to burn the cabin down
while I'm out I
did you really see a flower yes
little pink one silly thing
probably dead by now
get some sleep you look tired
you should starting to sound like mom
I'm not that tired
well you don't die easily do hello
you want till people
so many people who's there hello
door Dameon yeah okay yeah sure I saw
flower today shouldn't be long now
before spring or there's still a few
more weeks of winter left and that
flower girl died
what are you muttering about I heard the
voice today what I heard a voice as
clear as I'm hearing you there's no one
else in these woods Damian but it
sounded far away I should have followed
the voice but it trailed off and I had
to get back with firewood but we have
plenty of fun
Damian there is no one else in these
woods if there were I'm sure I would
have run into them by now you're not
getting enough sleep you need to sleep
are you seeing uh Paul I'm out what no
I'm fine I'm not even tired what about
you are you tired
you're always awake by the time I get
back I'm not a growing boy like you
little brother
oh please you're older by ten minutes
which is just long enough for me to be
in charge so shut up and go to bed
that doesn't make you in charge how does
that make you the boss just just be
careful
I don't know maybe I'm crazy but
whatever I heard out in those woods it
didn't sound too friendly
so just
just be careful I can take care of
myself don't slam the door you always
need to be right sometimes I'm right
sometimes I know things
well that's weird
what
that wasn't there before
how did I notice
[Music]
this doesn't make sense
is that you
to me hold on
hold on just a little bit longer just a
little bit longer sleep do you hear me
Celine Celine it
[Music]
Dameon you are hard man to find
what who are you we're Celine now
there's a hard woman to avoid if you did
anything to her
I'm easy there cowboy I've done nothing
to her I don't even think I could that
woman would carve my heart out and feed
it to me if she even saw me what then
why am I here what do you want from me
Oh Damien oh my poor sweet Damien I've
come to apologize do do I know you
of course you know dare I say you
probably know me as well as you know
yourself sorry bad joke couldn't help
myself
I know you oh come on Damien Celine
really did a number on you didn't she
mark and circle takes the square took
you out friend but you made it but this
doesn't make any sense we were just at
your party and then we were whoa easy
boy I'm gonna stop you right there
because I just don't have time for the
whole catching other thing no you need
to answer me how did I get here we're
even Emma whoa okay alright I'll just
summarize and it's best summarize by
saying that mistakes were made plans
weren't exactly properly executed the
right people started pointing fingers at
the wrong people and
a good night with some good friends may
have taken a wrong turn at some and okay
I may have made a deal to possibly make
sure that a certain lady couldn't go
around breaking anyone else's heart ever
again that was doing everyone a favor
but that's all in the past what matters
now is moving forward and all how
beautiful the future is gonna be with
you murderer
oh please you sound like that idiot
detective come on you're better than
that I don't need to hold your hand
through all this through all of what
just leave me alone
you don't realize this place is a dream
a never-ending starring role is the hero
but what is it hero without a villain a
villain every good story needs a villain
you honestly think that you're the hero
and all this oh well of course I am
who else could I possibly be my humble
upbringing my tragic backstory there's
no other role for me to play you're out
of your mind oh you you are going to
make the perfect villain in my story oh
yes sure that makes sense well you can
tell your story all you want to the
other prisoners oh come on
Damian let it go always the righteous
crusader pure as the driven snow acting
like you're the only one without blood
on your hands you stole everything from
me will
wouldn't even have anything in the first
place if it wasn't for me took our lives
you betrayed me
you betrayed William you even betrayed
serene well maybe if Celine hasn't run
off then we wouldn't be here right now
never good enough for Celine I gave up
[Music]
but that's all in the past and now I'm
here to show you I don't want anything
to do with your future
Disko drop dead and let me live my life
in peace live your life in peace oh my
friend what has she kept from him no
matter what tricks wind feisty what's
happened there is no ending for the
likes of us
what what have you done
Oh like I said I've done nothing but in
this place I'm gonna make something
beautiful
Damien McGee it's time to sleep so good
I I have no idea what just happened are
you all right no I'm not all right I've
never been less all right you need to
explain to me what the hell is going on
there's no time to explain why does
everyone keep telling you that I spent
God knows how long
chopping down trees with nothing but
time on my side and suddenly now there's
no time I'm so sick of being a pawn in
other people's games just give me a
straight answer for once
Celine
Am I
and no no Celine I'm so tired
everything I've done I've done to
protect you
but I was too late too sloppy
he's undone everything now but he hasn't
won yet Celine you can't keep this book
shut up you have no idea what I'm
capable of let me help you I remember
now
I remember what he did what we did
Damien
you have no idea what's really going on
here you're right
I haven't got a clue
but I know that even you can protect me
forever
[Applause]
it's not just about protecting you
everything's different now the mistakes
I've made that the people I've used the
things I've had to do to keep you alive
sweetie some things just can't be fixed
and I'm okay with that but if you let me
help you then maybe together
we can start to set things right you
look tired
I think you need to get some sleep
he can't remember the last time I slept
don't worry I'll protect you you can't
come back from this it'll change you
forever well he did say he wanted me to
be the villain maybe he should be more
careful with his wishes
just promise me one thing makes it fast
and stays dead
[Music]
you